President Trump has for now backed off
his threat to close the border with
Mexico to stop the flow of illegal
immigration into the u.s. the
president's threat to close the border
down completely would also stop the
nearly 2 billion dollars worth of goods
that flow across the border every day
and if the border was closed more than
trade between the two countries would be
at stake Mexico is one of the biggest
suppliers of fruits and vegetables to
the United States
Maria Villarreal is in the border city
of Dona Texas this is one of the busiest
times of year for people working in the
produce industry Holy Week starts
tomorrow and Easter is just seven days
away crews at the Grove farms Texas
facility are working around the clock to
make sure peppers avocados and mangos
are in the stores ready for customers to
take home everything in this warehouse
run by Tommy Wilkins is grown in Mexico
and shipped across the border by truck
today for us to have enough avocados for
Cinco DeMayo we depend on the production
out of Mexico right now we're in peak of
harvest if we did not have the supply
out of Mexico we wouldn't see the
guacamole that we have opportunity to
consume 52 weeks a year 14 billion
dollars worth of fresh produce comes
into the US every year from Mexico and
half of that comes through Texas ports
of entry the same ports of entry
president trout threatened to shut down
a few weeks ago in response to the
influx of immigrants illegally crossing
the border no EF the border was actually
shut down it would only take about a
week for distribution centers like this
to lose their supply and in just three
weeks you would see the impact in your
stores I never changed my mind at all
I'm a shut it down at some point but I'd
rather do just last month Customs and
Border Protection reported 92,000 people
apprehended crossing illegally the most
in a decade 8900 of them were children
to help with the influx acting
department of homeland security
secretary kevin McLennan recently
announced he would be shifting resources
Wilkin says they immediately saw the
impact our window across the border has
gone at least a full day it's just not
the best thing for the commodities that
we handle so then it does affect a
regular person it will give them not the
precious product that we would like to
offer dante Galeazzi is the president of
the Texas international produce
Association and represents hundreds of
farmers shippers and distributors in the
Lone Star State who are just as worried
politics aside businesses business trade
is there without the trade without the
flow we're gonna start talking about job
losses and no one wants to see that
doesn't matter what side of the aisle
you sit on US Senator John Cornyn is now
asking acting secretary michaleen and to
make this issue a priority in a letter
he wrote the diversion of front-line CBP
personnel from these ports and the
threat of a possible closure in the
future threatens to have a debilitating
impact on the overall health of Texas's
economy he asked in McClellan's a
long-term border strategy keep trade and
travel in mind because it affects the
flow of goods to the entire nation
meanwhile tommy Wilkins a man who's made
produce his life for over 40 years is
now wading through a political showdown
to deliver that produce and although the
solution seems simple he's not sure
everyone will be willing to come to the
table for the food supply either there
or here to be used as a political tool
is a little discouraging to me and
they're using the produce consumption to
battle the immigration issue
everybody Washington needs to go to work
agree we have a problem and fix it not
use our disrupt the food supply to do
that for CBS this morning Saturday media
via Donna Texas yeah I think people
don't realize how difficult that border
is to yeah just what we thought we
individual impact as you know trickle
down
I guess basic and sometimes when it hits
you at home like that's in your
refrigerator yes suddenly jumps all the
food yeah you wake up to it